the carolina panthers made it known that
general manager marty herney
will leave the team at the end of the
2020 season
a not all that unusual move if you know
you're going to do it go ahead and do it
and it's entirely possible and this is
where we get
skeptical about what really meets the
eye it was entirely possible that david
tepper the owner of the team was
concerned that word was going to get out
that
that they're looking at potential
candidates that's the balance you strike
once you know you're going to move on
from a gm or a coach how involved are
you in looking for
replacements and how concerned are you
it's going to become public before you
actually make it known the relationship
is ending
there's no way that david tepper the
owner of that team just rolled out of
bed this morning and said
i need a new gm this clearly is
something that's been planned it's been
strategized
and my guess is this is when david
tepper all along
planned to make it known that it was
going to be a parting of the ways and
panthers aren't going to use a
third-party search firm temper's a guy
he's one of the richest guys in the nfl
and he's brilliant and he's tactical and
my guess is he's had a plan in place for
a long time to make this move and he's
been implementing it
and unfolding it and today we all found
out about it but
i'm surprised that he waited as long as
he did
to make a change a general manager i
thought it would be inevitable after he
bought the team
but now it's upon us and now we have
five teams
looking for general managers as the end
of the season approaches shireen
yeah mike i think it's a decision that
was already made as well and especially
since he said he already had a list of
candidates and maybe it's a situation
where you have a list of candidates
anyway i know a lot of teams
do that have candidates that they have
in mind but also mike
i am thinking that they thought they
were falling behind the other four teams
who are looking for a gm and if you're
going to make that move now is the time
to do it and get on the train and
and figure out who your gm's going to be
and start interviewing those candidates
because we know those other teams have
started interviews they've announced
them they've gone through
some of the candidates and they have
probably the candidate in mind that they
want to hire are getting close to that
so the panthers if they were going to
make the move needed to do it and they
have done it
it's going to be a reverse of what you
usually see usually
the gm hires the head coach and in this
case the head coach is going to have a
say
in the gm we saw that in houston it
didn't work out so well for brian gaine
hopefully it works out
better for whoever the gm of the
panthers is
i'm not a big fan of this gm being hired
while they're still a head coach and a
coach in whom a huge investment has been
made
whoever takes that job knows going in
they're not going to just write a check
and buy out matt rule when they're
paying him
what is it seven eight nine million
dollars a year after only one season
as the coach of the team and that's the
challenge that david tepper is now going
to have
finding a general manager who is fully
on board with the structure then the
question is
who has the power does the coach have
the power
does the gm have the power and if the
coach has the power specifically final
say over the draft
and the 53-man roster it becomes harder
to hire a gm
because you have to be able to offer
to someone who is currently an executive
with another team whether it's director
of college scouting or some other
title less than gm you've got to give
them gm powers
or the team can say no you're not
allowed to hire him
that's why john lynch ended up being the
gm of the 49ers
kyle shanahan had all the power he
couldn't hire somebody from another team
he had to go to somebody who was
unattached and lynch of course was
working in
the media at the time same thing with
john gruden when he became the coach
of the raiders after one year reggie
mckenzie's gone john gruden's got the
power
they had to hire mike mayok he was
unattached i'm not saying these guys are
unqualified
but they're unattached and it makes it
easier to hire these guys because the
coach is in charge and
look i maybe matt rule's done enough
that david tepper
is giving matt rule the keys to the car
and matt rule is going to be the one
who picks the gm and it's going to be a
bill belichick type of a situation
where the gm is the one who was setting
the table for the head coach shereen
yeah and david tipper also said today
mike that it's going to be analytic
driven
and data driven and that was where the
philosophical differences came in with
marty herney and why they moved on and
that's a big part
of what matt rule does is the analytics
and and the data
and so that's who they're going to be
looking for is somebody who really
stresses that and that's what they want
in their organization and we're going to
see how that works out and
david tepper would not address whether
the the signing of
the signing of teddy bridgewater played
into that decision or not but
he did say that it was philosophical
differences so now they can get a new gm
and we'll see how much power or more
power that matt rule has now
but bridgewater messed with joe brady
the offensive coordinator
bridgewater knew the offense that brady
was going to run and it's worked they've
been better than i thought they were
going to be
they're not a playoff contender nobody
expected it everybody expected
2 and 14 at best so they have been
better under matt rule
and we'll see where it goes from here
this one quote stands out for me and i
remember
seeing it the first time i watched the
all or nothing series 2019 when it
focused on the carolina panthers
david tepper writing in the back of an
suv saying this the league is set to be
eight and eight
everything is fair in this league so if
you have better coaches
better gm's some advantages with
facilities advantages with
training management process whatever
those whatever is you know
analytics whatever that is to give you
an edge that's what you need
and you need a good quarterback that was
the moment
for me then i uh oh it's just a matter
of time before
ron rivera is gone and marty hearn is
gone rivera went last year
hernia goes now there will be a new gm
in
carolina one of the teams looking for
both a new gm and
a new head coach the houston texans
they've announced that they have met
with jim caldwell former colts and lions
head coach
to be the texans head coach now it's a
little bit
backwards to hire or to at least
consider
coaches before you have a gm and it
makes me wonder who's going to have the
juice in houston
and they said met i thought there was a
memo that said they can only do virtual
meetings
through the end of the season maybe they
maybe they're just taking the liberty
with the term and
nowadays that's how 98 of all meetings
happen anyway
but caldwell as a potential candidate to
coach the texans
that's fine as long as the next gm is on
board with caldwell being the coach of
the texans and i'd hate to think
that the texans are thinking seriously
about coaching candidates
until they know who the gm is going to
be sharing
yeah it seems weird mike that they would
meet with him now but it does fulfill
obviously the rooney rule but i hope
they're giving him serious consideration
and this
isn't just to comply with the rooney
rule which is
what it seems frankly right now but i do
hope if they're interviewing him they
give them serious consideration and this
isn't just to check off that box that
hey we
we've done our minority interview and
now we can move on with who we really
want
let's take this seriously and interview
some candidates who you really want to
hire and jim caldwell certainly deserves
to be in that
category of coaches you would seriously
seriously consider with what he did in
indianapolis and then frankly what he
did in detroit and what detroit's done
after he left there
but let's hope it's just not checking
that box mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports